we are taking calls at 6 1 7 830 4750
will go to our next caller caller tell
us I guess to begin with what's your
name and where are you calling from
we'll start there i don't think i got
the caller on yet let's see if we can
get our next caller on line okay caller
let's start with your name and where you
were calling from my name is Allison
come from Germany Germany alright well
this is a first what's your name I
braced ok great what's on your mind I
read recently in the newspaper that a
couple of 22 years separated because the
husband is the transporter and and they
are up to sixteen percent of people stop
talking to family members or friends
because they all come from yeah and I
think that's quite a lot actually it
strikes he was a lot yeah III can him I
don't know how I would be able to be
with a significant other who voted for
or supported Donald Trump I mean I it
totally makes sense to me I don't know
about you guys but it seems to me like
that would just be an exercise in
futility it would just be in the same I
mean I guess it depends on the reasons
why they voted for Donald Trump if it
was out of bigotry absolutely not but if
they thought that he was going to be
good for the economy and shake up the
establishment I think we're having a
conversation well but even though just
to me that they're ignorant yeah they
don't care about any other policies and
they're just very narrow-minded yeah i
mean that to me that makes sense you
know i don't know what you think may I
almost added to but I think it's quite
shocking that politics have such an
impact on personalized for people I
understand what you're saying I mean I
think that it goes to the completely
divided you know we have this country
the United States of America but there
are such differences between people in
of different political ideologies and
very often split among geographic lines
that you you it's not surprising to me
that you would have fundamental cultural
incompatibilities between sort of
northeastern progressives and you know
southern trumpets or whatever so yeah I
mean it's very interesting from a
sociological perspective but based on
some of the people I've met it I
completely understand it yeah yeah okay
i miss you i am pink very good what i
say i think we may be around a bit of a
delay given that you're calling from
Germany the the internet tubes may may
be a little bit narrow in our
communication but I really really
appreciate the call always great to hear
from our viewers and listeners in
Germany